karine roy camille non c'est à ces
camions ndar machado ici vous propose
une vie si on le joue eh bien on peut
sentir de ces chemins de détermination
et faire son propre schéma
alors pour cela il faut justement se
connaître soi même est freinée par les
autres se connaître soi même aidé par
les autres ça permet en fait de
comprendre comment perçoit mieux et
comment on problématise d environnement
dans lequel on évolue parce qu'il est
hors de question de l'entente du pouvoir
maîtriser l'environnement
par contre les fusions environnement
débat aussi le mais le comprend et le
percevoir de différentes manières c'est
gosling le manière en fait elle va être
complètement happé par l'environnement
par les événements qui se passe c'est
bien d'avoir une certaine forme de bons
soldes alors moi ça je vais compris mais
mon chemin a été très difficile pour le
comprend en fait ce chemin pour le
comprendre il a commencé quand j'avais 7
ans quand j'avais 16 ans les parents ont
divorcé alors bien sûr on dirait qu
ayant exceptionnel il ya 120 min 10
morts par an en france
sans la vie ça représente des enfants de
10 ans et est parfois c'est très bien se
passer mais chez moi ça s'est pas très
bien passé en fait il ya douze scène
originelle qui ont fait qu'ils m'ont
fait un petit peu qu'ils ont surpris nos
amis quand j'essaie quand je vois mes
parents se battre pour la garde de ma
soeur quand la présence moi je suis là à
côté
à les regarder et apparement comprend ce
qui se passe et à venir mais qu'est ce
que c'est que cette tournée
la deuxième deuxième scène j'ai lu un
petit peu avant que l'éminent ces
censeurs ou en fait je suis là je
reviens de la première journée cb et
vous savez on va distribuer du requin
qui va permettre d'apprendre à lire moi
je suis là je me souviens bien que je
suis appelé par ce truc là est en fait
une curieuse idée de fou mais qu'est ce
que c'est que ce truc
puis-je ouvre les pages et jusqu'au fort
mais je sais par image pour vendre
je suis d'origine c'est le seul moment
de goûter je regarde le papa maman il
faut faire avec ça et là personne
nommément
alors ces deux scènes origine est la
première à geron cherche quoi comme aux
affaires le premier problème que j'ai eu
c'est que je ne trouve plus ma place
dans la famille et saddam devait plus
tard ces symptômes d'un poster le
deuxième c'est que le pro le deuxième
avec cette histoire de 15 c b vous ne
trouvez pas un peu dur pour commencer
une carrière scolaire même salut quoi
jean maxime depuis quelques années c'est
encore en vie c'est pas voir tant qu'on
en dise et valoir
alors me jauger problématiser jeu prend
de la distance et c'est à ce moment là
quand j'ai vécu c'est celle là et bien
d'autres encore
j'ai un peu avec ce monde et la place
pour metz alors qu'est ce que je vais
faire
ben j'ai créé mon propre univers alors
dans cet univers là moi je suis un super
héros ou alors juste une vers là je suis
un super ou cei soit 1 compagnie d'un
animal à vanter je suis accompagné d'un
cheval super beau mon cheval fait 30
centimes l île en place dit ça criait à
ces circuits sont en synthétique et je
suis super bon à l'école je suis
vraiment trop - l'école
si vous saviez copie que j'ai rendu en
attendant des vins sûr que aujourd'hui
trois fois deux fois en primaire une
fois au collège alors
mais c'est pas grave parce qu'on pêche
continuent à vivre dans ce monde là
whaou j'ai un arc laser
j'ai un arc à ces lasers mais bon je
parle le faire par semaine à moudre dans
ce monde là je suis un champion je suis
un champion je suis du lpl champions 6
10 et puis c'est bon bien sûr j'ai
raconté mon histoire comme ça et puis
bien sûr d'un ballon de croix sauf les
personnes mêmes et c'est une femme qu'un
parcours de vie un prof est en fait
elles meurent un conte plein d'histoires
ses mots jeudi date avec l'idée vraiment
l'egypte allait beaucoup et c'est là
qu'on plein d'histoires et moi et bien
le fait que cette femme qui habite eu
tant de choses croit en moi et bien et
fasse semblant de croire bien sûr cela
ne pouvait pas le faste en angle droit
vinciane domine pas mais ça me donne la
pêche et je vis dans un jour un jour je
fais un truc un jour j'arrive à faire
quelque chose ray vraiment dans la vie
je le disais en introduction que l'on a
besoin des autres
effectivement en a vraiment besoin des
autres et c'est ce qui va se passer ou
l'adolescence alors mon adolescence je
rentre je rembourserai au dos j'ai vu
jusqu'à la troisième difficilement en
tension monte à 100 d'eads est tous les
ans une forme à ses côtés
un coup de vent stupid eu la main des
dettes et en fait je pouvais rater moi
je trouve ça fascine
je pouvais rien d'année je passe des
tests il passe en me passant jaffe ya eu
en moyenne entre annuler le premier
diplôme qu'on propose d'implanter un
manque d'adhérence mais c'est pas mal
parce que tant qu'on ait envie c'est va
devoir peut-être qu'un jour j'aurai à
les dire
et puis comment dirais je mais bon c'est
pas encore moment là vous êtes jeu blanc
j'ai toujours vu à des jeux que je
plonge alors je vais pas souvent au
lycée parce que c'est en tous cas
surtout les moments de roland garros
voyez suspendu tant que moi que c'était
et puis un jour et un jeton amoureux ont
heureusement une fille alors par contre
elle c'est une fille super sérieuses
elles ont laissé général elle travaille
d'arrache-pied et ont fait elle veut
elle a eu la mention de match et c'était
assez bien la purée dire que j'en ai moi
en fait cette ville est crackée est trop
mignonne de ressembler un peu à se
financer du corps est alors un jour en
fait il faisait beau et érable je suis
allée nathan un jour je lui rendais chez
les avants ont fait dans les herbes
devant chez elle et elle chute des taux
qui fait pour cent qui je les attendrai
il ya quelques avoir moyen bonne idée
quand elles arrivent et c est là en fait
une belle et la rive qui sortent son
père je levais je vais pas me lever pour
les salaires nous physique du regard
jean rochât joshua il dit il m'a dit un
truc qui maintient en vie mais il m'a
dit je te vois souvent toi il dit est ce
que tu es
qu'est ce que tu fous tu fous rien des
limaces me dit tu es une limace qu'à ça
alors moi je couds hélas si vous voulez
j'ai compris ce que je pouvais envoyer
aux autres et quand il me dit ça mais
c'est un certain que m'engage c'est une
formule clé en main ça me saoule je suis
vraiment à chaudes larmes et l'invs est
alors que d'autres applis d'aragon du
dégage tu as besoin d'avis c'est dans
cette zone
inutile ce que tu veux faire tout jeudi
au camp est si bas damien baudouy
fallait pas penser à long terme voire à
long terme la vie tu veux faire c'est
les vacances et tout du parement lui il
vit tu veux bosser
elle a en fait dit mais tu sais ça
ferait du bien beau c'est là qu'est ce
qui fait en fait à la place de mort
envoyées
je propose un truc on va travailler sur
terre et de motivation on attaque sur
ton cd et tu vas trouver djebbour
effectivement j'ai sauvé du but c'est
d'aller là depuis que j'ai commencé à
travailler que c'est pas mal en plus on
est ce que je vais aller des sous et je
fais des choses et c'est qu'il ya des
gens qui m'aiment bien et des gens
racontent une boîte me peine pour faire
du vélo c'est par la volonté c'est pas
mal donc ça va ça mais puis à l'écrit
est donc en fait je travaille tous les
huitièmes toutes les fins de semaine
je travaille pendant les congés
scolaires et ses achats et flippant et
j'obtiens les premiers diplômes le
président du plan qui sont insérés ap
avait loupé un mac pro est là en fait je
commence à trouver du boulot je vienne
ma vie et puis comment dirais-je
j'ai envie de voir ce qui se passe
ailleurs et du coup je parle je quitte
ma normandie natale pour aller à l'eau
c'est ce que l'on j'ai fait j'ai regardé
les statistiques de chômage des camps
même bien peu d'évolution depuis désisté
en fait ça mais c'était pas mal
dynamique et toussaint rhône alpes je
veux retrouver le long des rails nous
empêche commence en fait à faire des
petits boulots je peux vous dire j'ai
vraiment fait ni trop mais indique et
puis un jour en fait j'ai un bout en
bout du conséquent je charles des
camions frigorifiques dans les grand
frigo dans des grandes robes rouges du
chargeur pointer au sol la marchandise
départ est imminent et là vous savez ce
que j'ai rencontré les dames et déçu
dans ses branches les goûts j'ai
rencontré les études supérieures comment
ça se fait pas parce que j'avais des
collègues de travail le vendredi 10 v le
drame de vendredi de la nuit du vendredi
à samedi la vie du dimanche à lundi qui
en fait financer leurs études comme ça
c'est gagner des sous aidé en fait à un
mois quand j'apprends ça j'arrête moi
j'ai laissé scotché alors comment ça se
passe à la fin qu'est ce tu fais comment
comment faubert et c est moi donc la
femme pour moi la femme c'est un tout
sévèrement 9,6 inouïe
culturellement et puis alors j'ai eu des
files de m'inscrire en attaque mais je
me décide très tard vous savez ce qu'il
restait 1 place du blason des bleus
chinois
alors je fais du chinois vous imaginez
un flic comme ça ils sont vingt balles
pro ou capables et toulouse
j'ai fait du chinois je me suis ramassé
mais figurez vous cette expérience m'a
permis plus tard d'approché avec mon
directeur de thèse et d'avoir un contrat
entre en général ces énoncés soir alors
du coup j'ai filmé dans les frigos et là
je trouve un travail tu ne vas me
plaisait en fait je fais la réinsertion
sociale je travaille en fait avec
je travaille avec des gens qui sortent
de la rue et que mon gré jeunes
organisent leur travail les manager
coach fédéral c'est une histoire de vent
classement général
le phare elle s'arrête et moi j'aimerais
continuer ce travail de management
d'organisation dit ah mais je les matchs
diplôme alors on au tir d'un flash dj a
trouvé un autre emploi avec une énorme
alors je galère un peu chantée des teams
le début
son régresser experts avaient valu un
bon jeu l'état qui a proposé un truc et
je me résous trouve un poste de
surveillant dans un collège et la
surveillant dans un collège cette offre
puisque je suis entouré le prof qui
avait avec fish no discuté et on dirais
je a lancé pour les méthodes et qui
paiera et puis je rencontre aïchi tu vas
devenir un et richard et hayat richard
jerram accompagnait m'appuyer elle avait
publié pour devenir pour réussir des
études est effectivement là dans la
fumée jetez un oeil
je passe une licence pas une maîtrise je
passe en bo1 je passe un doctorat
j'en passe à moudre et le dr à regarder
apprendre ce que je faisais quand j'ai
su que le jamais en dollars est alors en
fait la presse le dr à la vie commence à
aller mieux mais je trouve un poste puis
un deuxième j'ai commencé avec ma vie
est là qu est ce que je fais je m'achète
un cheval dont la dame est là en fait je
commence à chercher super hein je
commence à travailler avec lui elle a 5
ans et jean ans s'appelle aminona
jugement j'ai pour toi
et là je travaille à lecce et ça se
passe pas bien
en fait l'homme elles nous est tombée à
émerger
il ya en fait on a rigolé des cibles et
je revis en dtm originel qui sont basés
à quelques ya quelques quand j'étais
petit j'ai l'impression que ma jument
que j'aimais tant que je rêvais crise
qui a travaillé avec elle et c'est ça se
passe pas bien
alors en fait mr je suis fort quand même
d'une expérience de plus il va passer
quelques quelques quelques diplômes et
c'est quand at il bien la moyenne toute
chose à manger etc
et du coup moi je commençais à potasser
des trains du bouquin gilleron contre
carole thomas qui en fait a eu une
approche de lévitation pauline thiery
qui avait filmé super la politisation et
convergents j'apprends je travaille et
c'est j durée vous aujourd'hui
eh bien je fais informations à 6 des
maréchaux gel dégel
une des personnes qui prennent une
responsabilité dans les entreprises et
manager des équipes à fonctionner est un
lieu de fonctionner ensemble
voilà lui donne à ma jument est
maintenant en fait gérés et
expérimentent s'entend super bien
continuer à progresser elles continuent
à condamner alors cette histoire assez
individuel en fait on a tous des
histoires comme ça qu'on a chacun de
nous a des marques pour atypique et en
fait ce qui est intéressant c'est que
ces expériences on peut les partager
vous avez conçu s'il devait introniser
un truc intéressant il disait
d'expérience c'est une lanterne mon
travail sur son bouquet qui n'éclaire
que le passé est en fait on a chacun des
parcours et c'est chacun de nos parcours
sont éclairés comme ça et en fait on
s'est parlé on verra par contre on a
tellement d'expériences différentes on
pouvait changer pour échanger entre eux
soit pour voir c'était faux a lancé m
si oui je pense que des déchets avec un
dj il s'intéressait à la personne
si chacun vu chacun d'entre nous lever
et je pense que cette prison si vous
intéresser aux autres si en fait on ne
peut pas imaginer à quel point que des
fois ça coûtait pas changer le monde
mais ça peut changer
l'existence est menacée